[Music]
in funny protest news protests are
always funny submitted by a hole sitting
next to Tift
oh who is sitting next to tip I am okay
a school banned the use of backpacks old
boy protested by carrying his books in a
microwave what a hard job microwaves are
[ __ ] this bull sounds like he gets
his ass kicked on the daily already did
they do that for safety right so kids
don't put guns and knives and [ __ ] in
their backpacks well so this one's funny
because their safety is that the bigger
kids backpacks we're hitting the little
kids on the head oh that's [ __ ] dumb
wait
so our generation was like you can't
bring backpacks to some schools cuz
they're like drugs guns and knives this
is in the UK so way to school bad
weather backpacks is they should ban the
[ __ ] little kids were all so [ __ ]
stupid keeps running the [ __ ]
backpacks you morons what the hell get
those kids out the [ __ ] school this
is a ridiculous ban because it's like
they're banning backpacks my red and I
forgot okay they banned because the
reason was because the backpacks were
hitting little kids if my kid was a kid
in school that got hit in the face every
day with a backpack oh yeah honey you
are so dumb back in my day we used to
pump the kids with the big bag supposed
to reduce it you're supposed to look
like you never studied ever that's what
you're supposed to do
yeah anymore remember Tony won Jump
Street the second one yeah sequel how
like what they used to think was cool
now it's the reverse I'm believing that
[ __ ] they didn't let us take books home
we had to yeah it's just your school
your school is pretty good alone we had
books in the classroom and then you're
supposed to write down the questions and
everything and and they print out like
homework for us and and so we just had
folders and [ __ ] I think we tried too
hard to be cool back there because I
remember the cool kids would just have
the binders and yeah I just want
that yellow one yeah oh just whatever
you put things are cool things with it
but then I think back now I'm like the
rather hat back I wasn't even trying to
be cool I just couldn't learn myself cuz
I learned [ __ ] I love so much school we
didn't have lockers either any kids only
the head lockers we had we had lockers
but it was like well I for PE yeah yeah
PE and then like like kids that were
like what do you call it not the magnet
but like ap or like the there were like
sonotubes that can take books ha yeah
but the regular students were in the
class because they will all get [ __ ]
tagged up and then ripped up and then no
lockers like they were lockers but we
didn't have our own lock my school is
hood - we used to share lockers broke
yeah we had so many students like in
like LAUSD like I just had way to share
lockers - nobody had a single Locker to
themselves I had my own locker
yeah because Burma in my school the
reason why they said that we didn't have
lockers is because of the beginning of
the year every class would give us our
own book and we would take it home and I
would stay home and then we'd have
another copy in class so that's the
reason why we didn't have lockers cool
oh that's pretty ballin 10 copies of the
same book yeah we even need one laptop
chargers yeah one at the office in the
one at home you never exactly made us
copy the pages everybody wanted to buddy
up with the locker buddy that was a
degenerate because they would never use
the locker everybody wanted to be my
locker buddy dude so then all you guys
that had lockers is because you had to
keep bringing your books
you're supposed to yeah or sometimes you
don't need the book so you just leave it
in the locker instead or you just want
to leave all your [ __ ] in there and then
per period you just get your stuff I
used to be all like jealous like I look
at their lockers on TV like you could
stuff people in them and I guard
Phoebe [ __ ] like yeah we had like the
locker that was like yeah and I didn't
want the bottom one over the top one cuz
the bottom ones annoying the crap
smatterings I'm like yeah when I move
schools to mark Keppel then I started
getting like lockers and stuff and I was
like this is cool I never even used my
locker and then sometimes I'll leave a
sandwich in there and [ __ ] juices
start flowing and goes down to the
locker below me I know what they have to
report it but since I don't use it I
don't even remember my combination oh so
they always have to come and like try to
like open it up my [ __ ] back you the
worst person ever days I was in the gym
and like the changing room that's where
we would keep our PE clothes
[ __ ] soy sauce and lotus roots the
[ __ ] kind young [ __ ] all right so
this is Jacob he was doing a silent
protest to this ridiculous ban by taking
his books yes a twin brother no it's the
same guy okay
you know with like open and inside and
then on top yeah and then he also took
it in a wicker basket that was funny
and then he wrote this whole like essay
about how he thinks the ban is really
dumb he gave himself Homer I know so it
necessary to turn that into did yeah
then he also used a plastic bag he goes
to like a legit school oz was wearing a
suit yeah gravity cool they're actually
studying the night a grammar school they
only learn grammar I don't know it's a
UK thing I don't know but like I don't
know what I mean seriously which is done
yeah we've got a cloud I'd have like you
smart [ __ ] I know good I'm
trying to make myself feel better right
now yeah he also took a lawnmower that's
where you put his back books you know
that [ __ ] to memory back in the day when
those kids would have [ __ ] roller
bags or [ __ ] yeah
that was that was before my my time oh
do we younger kids had the roller bags
do those roller bags were so crazy cuz
I'm like dude you're just giving an
audible for people to find you to kick
your ass yeah you know those kids would
get it the worst back in the day yeah
but their backs are great though because
my shits all crooked off to the left and
[ __ ] cuz I was leaning over one side
yeah yeah when you're traveling you have
luggage you're like oh this makes I
don't know how your schools were but as
soon as the bell rang for lunch those
[ __ ] would speed and Stampede
to the front of the line like they were
you were just here yeah and it's like a
gang of nerds just [ __ ] Bolton to the
front of the missile flames yeah it's
like it was I feel bad those definitely
times like kind of [ __ ] with those
kids back in the day too
I like I ran behind him was like mr.
flight I like lavish and I was like I
got picked on - it was like a chain of
command of getting picked on I got I got
bullied too and I feel like they're like
now doing some really successful [ __ ]
because what they're probably doing is
like hurting up and eating lunch so they
could study and finish their [ __ ] Oh
doesn't matter bats are so nice to see
stories like you know I have this one
homey ice - peer pressure him to like
always like just the matrix dig now yes
back problems get my wheelchair real
quick yes you [ __ ] bastard oh my god
[ __ ] up what kind of adults are making
these rules now like it just doesn't
make any sense I hope they're not our
age like we hear all these stories from
the UK mainly UK of all these like let's
settle for the for the I don't know but
what's the word was no fancy word yeah
oh let's settle for the snowflakes but
it
there's no fleek generation let's settle
for the for the I don't know like it's
everywhere now we just gotta you know
everywhere is like you know and you know
the stuff something good comes out of it
too it's not like it's all like bad to
me well I mean there's a lot of the
movements like you can call that people
can call it either being sensitive or
snow flaky but it's also like making
change you know what I mean like giving
a voice to people but I think it does
[ __ ] it up for how we approach things
now like people don't really fine yeah
like we all got it like step on
eggshells now everybody has to be
careful I'm making scrambled eggs
everywhere dude I don't give a [ __ ] and
that's why we don't get a sponsor do
yeah but I do give a [ __ ] sometime
because I'm poor that's the part where I
give a [ __ ] right look at what some of
these other people have which I
shouldn't do I shouldn't be looking at
somebody else's dinner plate but I'm
hungry but these guys they're very smart
and you know I think like because what I
did started as something that was fun
you know and I can't take that fun part
out of it now so it's like if yeah you
know so if you look at it as a business
it's very very stupid what I do it's
like you're not looking at it like
you're not trying to make your fake
bigger but I started YouTube having fun
so I can't undo that part right yeah so
if there's a value freedom like first
and foremost that's probably why like
other people you know they want whatever
success or whatever they find is
successful to them so it's like I want
to start a business and it's for profit
and that's their goal versus like our
lifestyle we did it because we wanted
freedom and then the money's just a
supplement our lifestyle but I think
that's the thing it's like if you are
just aware enough you're never gonna be
that problematic you know Sam's that's
the thing is like I I dude I try as I
get older like you know the reason I
even got into hip-hop is so I can say
whatever the [ __ ] I want and that's what
rap kind of gives you that freedom right
like you can be reckless but like I've
never been like a like I don't go out
saying crazy [ __ ] like say [ __ ] the
police was like crazy back then and now
it's like not crazy
how'd you cos cops just ruin their own
reputation but like but yeah I mean I
just say like I think more than more
than the music part like I like you know
I'm into comedy and you know stand-up
and all that [ __ ] and just podcasting
like I don't give a [ __ ] what I say on
that [ __ ] you know but that [ __ ] after I
do it when I second-guess myself I have
an inner conflict with myself I'm like a
little [ __ ] like why do you care about
them like I do care about it we said I
need that inner voice right I need that
inner voice to tell me hey you probably
should have say that right right and the
other side of me which is like 90% of me
is like now [ __ ] that upload I just see
what happens right
she's my inner voice so I just say
whatever the [ __ ] I want until she
corrects me like oh okay sorry yeah I
think you got to just get with the times
you know like whatever is socially
acceptable at the moment because when we
were growing up everybody said the
n-word and no one said the n-word they
just actually said the word in lyrics to
each other like and it was in I don't
know like I was encouraged to by my
black friends you know you're like but
people still say it right but then
likely they can't say it publicly and in
you it's way different now I don't know
if you could have said it publicly
before yeah I mean like even Eminem said
it like it's my thing is it's like back
then of course like you know non black
kids would say it back then I'm not
saying it's like right or wrong I'm
saying they would say but they would
have gotten flag too if there was more
[ __ ] outlets where that she was
public right like cuz the more people
could come together in a neighborhood
but now people in they they feel like
that they shared on these platforms
that's not your neighborhood it's like
everywhere you know you got to be ready
for what the [ __ ] that comes with that
you can you sit around your friends who
are cool with you but then like you say
it outside of that neighborhood and then
other black guys hear you they're like
what the [ __ ] right but then also
another word is like [ __ ] like we used to
call each other fact all that was
calling every neighborhood that was oh
that was a word of that wasn't whatever
that was a term of endearment like we
used to call you in the sky like that's
that's some hood [ __ ] well even though
I'm not gay like that like people that
work even hood would say like that's gay
that's gay whatever it was never good
because um people start enough people
were like that shit's not okay so that's
why that's that's what I'm saying no you
got to get with the times right like
whatever socially acceptable at the
moment at the moment it was okay to be
homophobic it was okay to call each
other gay and stuff like that that's why
I don't you see to me it's like when I
hear like standard come you know like
cuz like louis c.k and bill birds talked
about this kind of culture right like
being snow thick and stuff i get where
they're coming from but my other side of
it too is like bro like just get with
the [ __ ] times to your oldest [ __ ]
like you got to know the world is
changing you know I'm saying like to me
it's like it's kind of a old mentality
to to not understand that like yeah [ __ ]
isn't okay anymore - yeah like you know
I mean like there's thing like all
tradition doesn't mean it's good [ __ ]
you know I mean like [ __ ] changes and I
think like that's something that people
have to adapt to - you know what I mean
like I didn't know their issue though is
people don't want to understand context
anymore they hear trigger words and they
get angry do you think that's what
they're talking that's laziness yeah
yeah it's like with comedy it's always
about perspective you know what I mean
and context matters and comedy a lot
right you know and I think because and I
run me one is with comments all the time
right they hear one thing for example
this is like the hottest thing that I
see right now somebody says anything
black legal racist right automatically
he goes I was reading a quote one and
then a long time ago and then it had the
n-word in it and I was like hesitant but
I ended up saying it and then I just got
no you but even something small like
this they're like you you could read an
article and say this it was like there
was a black man they wouldn't mean a
black man it's like it's right there
like that's racist people like to throw
these adjectives around because context
doesn't matter anymore and I feel like
with stand-up comedy context is huge
some people a little bit extreme you
know obviously like like bill burr and
Louie CK are on that far end because
they're extremely opinionated about
their [ __ ] and they're kind of sometimes
it comes off as a
reckless but you know what that goes
back to what you guys are say it's not
the times so they'll still have their
demographic and people still [ __ ] with
them you know yeah my other thing is I
don't care what people share it's like
everyone just has to deal with the
consequences that's all it you know I
mean it's like yeah if you know that the
times like that now that way and it's
fine you you keep doing you but just
know now now there's gonna be concert
with everything you know so it's fair
all around it's like fair play for
everybody
[Music]
[Music]